scp-49 also known as the plague doctor
is a humanoid entity contained by the
SCP Foundation its appearance is that of
a medieval plague doctor wearing a long
black robe and beaked mask scp-49's
anomalous properties manifest when it
touches living organisms which it will
attempt to cure of incurable diseases by
killing them and reanimating them
through an unknown process this process
turns the victim into an instance of
scp-49-2 a Mindless zombie-like entity
scp-49 is capable of speech and seems to
believe that it is performing a
necessary and merciful service it is
shown a preference for targeting humans
but it will also attempt to cure animals
and other organisms despite its attempts
at healing scp-49 is considered
extremely dangerous and is to be
contained at all times its true nature
and Origins are unknown but it is
believed to have been active since at
least the 14th century